[Music]
it's a very name-droppy story but we
were hanging out with kevin bacon
who i hope we have on the show soon um
and kevin told us an interesting story
of course there's no more recognizable a
face than kevin bacon's he's got such a
unique
luke
that uh a makeup artist friend of his uh
put prosthetics on him
he went to all the places that he
couldn't go to with his kevin bacon face
he went to the grove and you know
universal city walk and all these very
public touristy places and he said
something along the lines of people were
less friendly to him he interpreted as
people being rude
he realized that it wasn't they weren't
being rude they just weren't being extra
friendly for all those years he had
gotten the kevin bacon like extra
friendly treatment from the guy at the
cinnabon be careful you wish for yeah so
he ripped off the mask and he was like
i'm getting bacon
look at this you just got bacon
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
from wondering this is justin long and
you are listening to life is short life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
which brings us to this segment of our
show called you just got baconed
i'm here with my brother christian hello
yeah there are two sides of being
a recognizable person with me it's it's
nothing they have kind of a blase
response but sometimes they have a very
loud response and when we were i was
walking here to the studio today and
these girls
who had gotten like 10 15 feet past me
started yelling my name jostan josh dan
all these people looking at me
and they wanted me to turn around and i
was and you know 10 years ago i probably
would have and they wanted you to turn
around not necessarily because they
wanted to meet you but because they
wanted to verify their suspicion that it
was in fact you yeah um but i wonder how
lena dunham my guest today would handle
something like that she's i think far
more recognizable and also seems a lot
better equipped to handle moments like
that she probably would have handled
that situation differently she wouldn't
have like you did
run after the girls screaming don't say
my name in public she would have handled
it very differently she probably would
have gone up then and introduced herself
and been very respectful
he's kidding i just kept walking which
is also probably not the right way to
handle it um she is of course the star
and creator of the classic tv show girls
on hbo i think it is a classic and we'll
go down a shirt of course um can
something be a classic so shortly after
it was off the air i don't know if there
are rules for that i know how long is it
cars you need 20 years to be considered
is that the room as far as i know really
so the station wagon that pontiac
bonneville we had when we were kids
that's a classic classic and i only know
that because our father used to brag
about that
we're driving a classic
and be like yeah technically but
not really yeah
i really think you think of like a cool
car anything of so some like shitty
paper i wrote in fifth grade is now a
classic
yeah um she's done something else that
i'd like to talk to her about which is
she has maybe gone too far you know lean
too much into the public she's she's
leaned too far in oh [ __ ] that's good
yeah she um she's dumbed herself in by
doing that uh
a lot of her mistakes have been are
mistakes that people are aware of
because of the public
life that she lives willingly yeah she
you know yeah she'll
show pictures of herself from yeah the
gynecologist's office you know like
about to undergo another procedure
that she she opens her personal life up
and makes it part makes it art and makes
it um
and it's art that is relatable i think
too because of that because it's so
honest
and she she talks about this but
i i found it sort of inspiring that she
does that
in order to help other people and to
make other people feel more comfortable
who are going through a similar thing or
so there's something very altruistic
about totally um her public life i don't
i don't think she gets credit for that
enough i think she gets right like agree
or disagree like whether you agree or
not yeah with her politics or her
whatever i don't think you can disagree
with
her motivation and i think her
motivation is very admirable pretty
admirable yeah
and uh lena in addition to to girls and
the things that she's already known for
she will soon be known for another
classic work uh a podcast called the c
word yeah it's it's a podcast that is
all about women throughout history who
have been called crazy
she's also got a great way with words
and that extends even to texting
we're both single and kind of struggling
with being like wow what are we like
gonna date in the world now and
how do you do that i'm i'm 40 she's much
younger um but she said uh
she was like agreeing that like dating
now is weird she said entering into new
relationships sounds so hard i can't
even believe it it's like going to the
gym with a hangover such a great
sentiment good writer it's a good writer
good brain yeah hell of a brain good
brain in that head so i want to we're
going to pick it we're going to pick up
that old brain of lena's and um we hope
you guys enjoy the brain picking sesh
and uh coming up after this
and the point is to get somebody at
their most vulnerable yeah it's like
it's like it gets spicier and spicier
just because the questions heat up i was
like that sounds awful so awful yeah
wrestling with like gastrointestinal
i don't do well with any sort like
i don't want to do anything that shows
i'm fun
why why is that that why well a cause
i'm not fun but be true i don't thank
you but because like i don't want to do
anything where they're like really
trying to get you like to be who you
really are it's like i'm already who i
really am right right i don't need the
push it's like i have this really dumb
tattoo speaking of things that you do
before you gets over my friend beth and
i were uh getting tattoos and the tattoo
artist was like do you guys want to
tattoo each other and i was like yeah
why would i pass up this opportunity so
i did a tattoo on beth it's not great
it's on her shoulder it's a little
little kind of like
design using the tattoo gun oh okay
design of her creation no mine we
tattooed each other and we were like
let's not tell each other what it says
what
yeah you have a you're close enough with
someone who trusted you to do that
and vice versa i mean i think there were
other things at play but yes i do trust
you this is pretty sobriety yes i trust
i trust
and i trust anti-anxiety medication no
uh and then she tattooed on me
be yourself that's great
which is great but it's sort of like
that's like the one thing i don't have a
problem with
so sort of like she should have tattooed
me with like be less yourself yeah
moderate your behavior a little bit
around other people yeah i'm a creative
force whenever the be yourself tattoo
comes out i'm just like this is like or
like it's right where they take my blood
and they're like the nurse is always
like be yourself that's great i'm like
humiliated it should be like insert
needle here that would have been a lot
a lot better it looks uh like it hurt a
lot it looks like it's in a vulnerable
it turned and she also had to go oh
she's not an experienced tattoo artist
so she had to go over i almost said i
could tell but it's but it's actually
like not bad it's not the worst it's not
the best it's sort of a like a primitive
hand yes like a crumb if crumb were to
draw you know 100 and i have some dumb
tattoos at least that one was like
administered to me by a friend who i
will always love it's a good story yeah
i think it is kind of an okay story
what'd you put on her
it says i'd like write her text and i'd
be like nobody but you beth nobody but
you like just saying so it says nobody
but you on her shoulder but it only sort
of says that because i was less bold
than she was with like really digging it
because you have to like
i thought you could just like graze the
skin but it's like no you're really like
kind of slicing in there so
my only tattoo story is the beginning of
those stories the only cool part i got
drunk with green day which was fun that
is cool that's cool that's it that's so
cool that's for the cool entrance in
fourth grade when i had no friends i
lied to everybody and said that i had
green day tickets for my birthday like
dookie had just come out i was like sure
i had the cassette tape and i was like
sucks you guys don't want to be my
friend considering i have 15 green day
tickets for my birthday and then
everyone was like oh real maybe we want
to come and i was like never mind i can
only bring my friends from camp like it
was an incredibly ornate lie which
you maybe hadn't thought through because
then
you know if it works yeah and you know
then you don't have the tickets it's
awful wait so you were drunk with green
day drunk with green day and they were
incredible they couldn't believe that i
didn't have any tattoos which i i found
flattering because they thought
you were the kind of cool guy yeah i'm
proof justin that you don't have to be
cool to have tattoos well i i think
you're cool and i think you're uh cool
in a way that it makes sense that you
have tattoos whereas that's nice i i
felt like i was kind of benign and like
there was an innocuous quality to me
that like i i was flattered that they
suggested otherwise you're like i'm the
lacroix of people yes exactly but like a
lesser lacroix flavor even like uh like
a tangerine yeah totally get it yeah
but they so later that night
i said well you know what i should get a
tattoo and they and my girlfriend at the
time suggested a heart he was into
hearts
and i have to say i know who that is
yeah well yeah well because they're
notorious for their interest in hearts
so if you're trying to like keep it
private yes it i read the daily mail
justin i know what's going on yeah it
was clearly yeah gold in my air
um yeah so so it was true yeah drew
wanted a heart and so i i uh they did
the stick and poke billy joe asked his
security guy who i think was also
responsible for other things in his life
to
get him a needle
and i'm at the biggest germophobe and i
didn't question where the needle came
from i didn't go like who's it been with
who's it been it you were like i'm ready
nope that's the level of drunk i was and
billy joe
um stick and poked your ankle yeah
that's really cool which
it was and then and then a couple weeks
went by and it kind of
scarred and then faded and started and
after a while it looked like like little
ring worm it looked like a little red so
now you have to stare at it yeah i have
two stick and poke tattoos ones on my
butt once on my side both of them were
done by my best friend jemima kirk who
is really cool it's very cool very hip
very cool yes she did them both like one
day we were like gonna go see i remember
we were gonna go see what are those
movies that paranormal activity yes but
then it was like sold out and so we just
stayed home and she stick and poked me
and then another time she did it on
screen for a movie the one on the ass is
for
the mo that was the movie yes i did it
for time she did it on screen in tiny
furniture
and she she's really good because she
like really kept the continuity going
she was awesome and she did it like i
was like i don't think i'm a good enough
actor to pretend i'm getting a tattoo on
my butt so she was like let's just do it
oh my god and then the other one was
done when we were staying home because
paranormal activity was sold and the one
on the butt you knew what that was it's
a snake wrapped around the moon that was
what you wanted to do because it's
impressive that she was able to she's
really good like her if you see one
she's done you just think it was like a
slightly drunk professional tattoo
artist she's very good and the one on my
side is
she had a dog for a long time named a
boy named rosie and he she tattooed
rosie's head on my
she's really i mean she's she's a
professional or she's a painter and so
she brings her and she keeps like a
little book of her tattoo ideas and she
has it and she has her needles and
everyone can pick their thing out of her
book like it's kind of a good operation
she is going yeah i'm surprised she's
only done two because you have several
you have many i had to count them
actually for the other day for a doctor
for some reason he was like how many
tattoos do you have and i was like i
don't know and he's like well for a
doctor weird it was like had to do with
like uh
blood donation
and uh i stopped at 40. i have more than
40. i was like i can't do more than this
and on that i'm sure there's a spectrum
of ones that you regret versus you
mentioned like i mean that that one you
know
there's a couple i got there's a couple
i don't love like i kind of can accept
them all as just like you know a kind of
cozy reminder of where i was in my life
i have another one on my butt that is
the that is the neon sign of
that restaurant the odeon in tribeca yes
which
it's a cool dining dinery yeah it's the
first place i ever ate out as a kid like
i we i went there for brunch when i was
like a week old and it was and it's
where my friends and i usually went oh
so it had high school and then it was
where my ex-boyfriend and i had our
first date or a second date like it had
things about it and then i got it but
it's like orange and pink aren't like
great
color on the skin like it reads pretty
right it reads pretty skinned as easy
and also like
this kind of amazing thing happened i'm
delighted to see this podcast which is
after i got it the odeon was like free
food for life and i was like okay this
is the best choice i ever made and then
i went and like ate a lot of stuff and
then afterwards they just like brought
me a bill and i wasn't going to be the
person went up to him and was like just
you know the word odion's tattooed on my
ass like i was promised free food like i
was gonna just let it
slide and i still go and i still pay i
love it there yeah here's here's why
here's why i know i would have said
something about the odin thing when i i
used to do this when i did the apple
commercials the mac commercials oh yeah
i had one yeah i i had a 15 discount
i'll say it again
15 discount when they first told me i
was like oh that's cool half off i'll
tell you no that's not enough yeah 15 of
apple products yeah so did you ever get
like a choice of like five free things
before it kicked over to 15 um
yeah they sent me an iphone when they
first came out we were doing the iphone
commercial
yeah if you're doing an iphone
commercial you deserve an iphone it's
it's good for them to have the guy who
wraps iphones holding an iphone so i
couldn't set it up for some reason and i
can it is boring it's hard it was hard
and at the time i think i had something
about my credit i had been traveling and
blah blah blah but i just couldn't and i
was like well whatever i'm fine with my
flip phone i have a phone i don't need
this new i didn't even know what it did
and yeah so i was with john hodgman who
played the pc and we were actually
recording one of the commercials and uh
if they had had a b-roll of the
in-between
it would have been the most effective
commercial because he in the commercial
i
you know arrogant whatever matt guy is
teaching pc well pc this is what an
iphone does and and then in between
takes john who had set his up was
showing me how it works and i was like
holy [ __ ] this is insane this thing is
incredible you guys see what's happening
look at this it's amazing and uh and
they and so i went i remember all the
executives would sit in the back of the
we were recording this big
uh you know white expanse and yeah so i
went back there and i was like you guys
um i talked to the prop guy and he has
like six extra phones i would love to
you know use one he said he could give
me one and at the end of the day this
kid came up to me and he goes uh he's
like teenager and he was like i missed
her along like kind of like the kid in
the simpsons like the pimply kid in the
same she was like mr longa unfortunately
like there are the props and i realized
he was telling me i couldn't have one i
was like oh he goes i'm so sorry that's
okay it's not your fault i'm just sort
of surprised about a week later i was
photographed with a flip phone and it
was sort of like a thing it was like
look at the map
and they that they could have avoided
that they could have avoided it and
that's when they sent me they called my
agents and they were like you know he
should be using an iphone and they're
like well you send them one yeah yeah
that's incredible
but the 15 i've i remember going to the
apple store and saying this is you know
then they would say i would say you know
i i have this discount and they would go
oh yeah no okay i know we know that
you're the apple guy and uh they would
always ring it up as a ten percent
discount so that yeah so then i'm faced
with whether or not to say
it's actually fifteen percent you know
can you give me the extra point no it's
really hard and also all of those things
like i the thing i always say is like
the thing that's the things that
celebrity are good is good for is like
is like
like occasional charity restaurant
reservations
and like
you know airport assistance like those
are just
and besides that the rest of it yeah the
rest of it like i really am so pleased
that i can um get my father like a
birthday dinner my dad always wants
reservations at places that like aren't
even cool and and everyone can get in
any time like where but he likes to know
he has a reservation it'll be like a
random sushi place on his street where
it's like you could go at any time of
the day and it would 100 be the exact
paper you wanted but it makes him feel
safe to know we have a reservation so
like
i'll be like don't worry i'll have my
people get on it and then he is so
impressed with me and loves me and i'm
like i did nothing it's like i got you
into a chipotle like you don't
apparently christopher walken used to do
that at the chateau marmont when he
would stay there he'd call down at like
four ten you know and he'd be like yeah
like a reservation for one and they were
like yeah and for in five minutes and
they were like mr walker it's totally
open there's no one here and he's like
okay so that's one
i understand though because you want to
feel safe and like you know you're going
to be okay yeah yeah you want to be
taken care of yeah so you mentioned
those are the good things okay so
there's a lot of bad then i would
imagine i mean yeah i mean you know
you've you've experienced it like it's
but not the degree that you have i have
to say and and i think
part of that is your your reach is much
you have it's much more expansive and
and your voice is a lot louder and as it
should be because it's an important one
and it's very nice of you to say it
depends on the day but no it's true and
and i i should say this too uh speaking
of your voice you are going to lend your
voice to a podcast uh a new podcast
called the c word uh luminary which is
out now luminaries it's out now it's a
it's an app it's a podcasting app so you
could even hear this podcast on it
because it lets you play all podcasts
cross promotion yeah
nice we just high fived for the viewers
at home and it was great it was great it
was pretty pretty it was pretty clean
and we kind of had good uh connection
and connection and hand overlap so um i
looked at his friend for all the
amateurs you got to look at the other
person's elbow elbow that's right elbow
eyes but um so yeah it's pot luminary's
an app that allows you to listen to a
lot of podcasts and then also
listen to like luminary exclusive
podcasts so it's cool because it's not
just me it's like you know uh trevor
noah and celeste barber and my friend
leon nefak who's a really amazing
journalist has a really great true crime
podcast
and is this this a new app it's a new
app and i love being part of a new app
it makes me feel like i'm really on the
cutting edge and i love everybody yes
and i love to say to people like oh yeah
if you want to buy the app and like i
have a little code i can give to people
and it makes me feel really um
makes me feel like it makes me feel
probably just 1 90th of how you felt
when you represented mac to the world
uh-huh well i had a hard time yeah
maybe you didn't love people
maybe you found it embarrassing when
people would ask you questions about
like what day does the new computer come
out or whatever well they would often
ask me technical questions that i was
not at all equipped to answer i know
enough to this day i'm technically it's
so crazy i once was in a board interview
to to buy my first like little i was
buying this like little studio apartment
in a building that was all literally all
people over 80 like three or four people
would die in the building a week
like there was always a stretcher
outside
because it was just where jews go to die
in brooklyn there were i had a neighbor
called rob who was i don't know like an
85 year old music a former musical
theater actor and he died on my watch
three times like he kept getting taken
away on a stretcher and then i'd see him
in the hall and he'd be like oh my god
good news
he's here
so um but they
were really like adamant that i tell
them why hbo was so expensive and i was
like i don't
price hbo that's really funny that's
true and the whole interview is like do
you want to know anything about like if
i party how many pets nope you just want
to know why hbo comes so much and
i wish i were able to give you that
information why is this so much nudity
does there have to be so much nudity on
the girls oh my god it's so fun when you
like when my grandmother's friends my
grandmother made she rest in peace my
grandmother had the best response which
was after her she had some like if my
grandmother was 92 she had some like 80
year old friends who had seen the show
who talked to me about it
she called my mom and she was like lore
vivian jerome asked me why lena's naked
so much on television and why she had
sex in that pipe in her movie and i said
viv it's just what they do these days
so she was the cool one for getting to
answer yeah she loved it she was like
she loved my grandma's favorite thing
was to criticize us really intensely and
then say to everybody else like i love
my grandchildren no matter who they are
like
we got the brunt of her hate and then
she could look incredibly accepting
about our general just like like her it
was her nightmare like every one of her
grandkids is either like queer or cover
like trans or covered in tattoos or like
my grandmother would [ __ ] her pants if i
mean in fact i hope they don't listen to
this because just knowing that i have a
tattoo that has now since faded it is
too much my grandmother was really my
grandmother was like you're not going to
be very indexed and i was like crazy
news grandma i wasn't going to do it
anyway
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
you don't want to be buried no i don't
want to be buried do you want to be
married no no no my body right although
my dad i talked to him recently my dad
who's catholic i never i can't believe
i've never because i think about the
afterlife all the time it's my whole
life i'm actually the best thing about
getting really sick in your 20s i know
this sounds like not to take it like to
a dark place but please the thing i
always tell people is that the thing
about getting really sick spending a lot
of time in the hospital a lot of time
thinking about your body and its
fallibility and mortality is like
i do not have the same anxiety around
dying that i used to i don't want to do
it right now right right but i feel as
though my biggest fear around dying was
like what if i'm in a lot of pain before
and i've experienced what it's like to
be in a lot of pain and i got through it
and i understand that there's people who
help you through it and that your pain
is you know like modified through and
also
so comforting
it's really nice because i'm like
there's actually nothing i can imagine
going through you know do i want any of
it no but
if it were to happen i actually
understand i have the inner resources to
deal with it and that dying is not the
worst thing that can happen to a person
not to labor the point and dwell in the
darkness but the death fixation is so
you mentioned like the pain the
potential pain
but it's not the nothingness it's not
the like lack of
not to be too much like of like this
nothingness doesn't seem like viable to
me like i just don't it's like on a
purely
like i mean obviously not a scientific
level because i don't know what science
is but just on an instinctual level
i don't
feel like that's where we're going i
don't claim to know what it is but and i
also feel like if you're a person who
like likes life and thinks life is
really interesting and wants to try
everything why wouldn't you want to try
dying at the appropriate time i feel
really lucky i've that my um death
fixation was lifted from me because it
was a huge part of my childhood it was a
huge part of my teens
yeah i mean it's in your work a lot and
that was you think the result of having
gone through this illness this really by
the way we should talk about that i mean
you had you had a hysterectomy
early i did it was young i was 31 i was
31 when i had a hysterectomy and i that
was my
12th surgery so it had been a ride to
get there so i was thinking about this
when they when you you talk about them
taking out your you i mean like they
removed don't want to brag but i've had
i don't want to get you guys too hot and
bothered but i've had be careful i've
had three organs removed and one of
which jesus christ so yeah you got what
do we got here we got the uterus i don't
have a uterus yeah i don't have check
please i don't have a i don't have a
right ovary okay good god for anyone
who's fact checking i accidentally said
my left ovary had been removed on
instagram because i was still a little
out of it for man for all the lena
dunham nerds who were like um you know
what you actually did
don't have a right ovary i don't have a
uterus i don't have a cervix which is
technically not an organ but i do love
talking about it because it means i
don't need pap smears anymore oh that's
cool now i don't know how cool it's cool
but i imagine it's cool it's cool when
you tell your girlfriend so like oh yeah
um
yeah lucky but i do have a left ovary
and i do have lungs when i used to do
that
um but you uh so and i think it was the
uterus that you mentioned the doctor
said oh my god like that's the worst i
mean i don't know how they deliver the
news this is the silliest universe i've
ever seen yeah so he told me it was a
real real sack of crap but and it was
interesting because you know women are
so
i talk about this a lot i like won't
shut up about this and they're
definitely people i mean i don't really
look at my instagram comments anymore
but when i do they're definitely people
who are like we get it you have your
uterus removed
but some people are starving
but well how do you reconcile that i
mean what
that speaks to a larger thing too which
is you are
you
share a lot i mean it's safe to say that
you live in a very public how do you
then
how do you deal with that how do you
separate because i don't know what
that's like something i've realized in
the last year specifically is like if
you're a person who likes to share and
if you're a person who likes to live in
an open way you also have to surround
yourself not necessarily with people who
are like that but people who accept that
about you i mean i've definitely been in
relationships and friendships where
where people kind of thought like why do
you have to do this like they treat it
more like a compulsion and i try to
explain like this actually my work yeah
this is what i do this is the way that i
express myself i see i don't know you
that well and when we were texting you
text it you text um you texted a photo
of yourself at the gynecologist's office
which is not i'm not saying anything out
of turn like it's stuff that you put on
instagram and it was my i was covered
yes you were covered i felt it was
appropriate when i responded with some
you were like oh i'm i'm taking myself
out for on a date and a photo of like
and i made a joke about not a funny one
but a joke was funny consensual i hope
you have consensus consensual great
consensual sex and as soon
as i sent it it was so funny oh god but
god forbid it's met with like
okay like that scene and i'm jumping
around a lot with in the first episode
of the second episode of girls with
robiglia where i make the date rape
jokes which is based on a real thing
that i did to a guy at a party okay
there's a i have to contextualize the
scene is for those of you haven't seen
it lena is applying for a job mike where
bigly is the boss and they're getting
they're actually flirting and getting
along so well yeah it seems like we're
going to fall in love like mike's always
like if that scene had gone a different
way we like spend the rest of our lives
together and it's so organic and there's
chemistry and like you guys seem and
it's nice because you've been dealing
with adam drivers kind of like more
solidistic character yeah and then
rough hang and certainly not attuned to
your needs and here's a guy who seems
like oh man this is and you made this
great joke but it's a great date rape
joke joke about it he went to syracuse
and you said this incidence of date rape
and then i'm like so like statistically
i was like i said something about like
statistically like
oh he said i have a friend who went
there and she got raped like was it you
it was something like no no it's it's
the statistics like took a nosedive and
and it happened to correspond when you
left the school oh yeah the statistics
change yeah it's a great joke and per
bigly's character just like does a 180
i've been talking about faith it's great
acting and he does not which by the way
his reaction is like that of someone who
date raped someone like that totally
totally that is what has occurred and
yes and that joke i remember thinking
that's 2012. that's 2012 and not
everyone loved it i mean not everyone
loves any joke i make but but there were
definitely people who were like that and
there was a couple people people who
read the script who said that's not
funny ah interesting but isis but i was
like a
i mean at that point i hadn't been
public about my own like assault
experiences i didn't kind of talk about
those for another couple of years but i
i just felt like if i can't make this
joke i mean
this is a whole other area no this is
what it's safe to do what isn't safe to
do it's very complicated
and but i i remember being at a party
like a year before girls started and
making there was like some like like
kind of like
you know some kind of like brooklyn-y
cartoonist like the kind of person i
would have like sort of awkwardly tried
to date when i was 22
and i made a syracuse date right like
seems like the city got a little safer
when you left kind of thing
and it was just so unsuccessful
so unsuccessful and it's interest the
other day i actually like i still i
forget
because i have so many great
collaborators who i can make all kinds
of jokes too yeah
the other day i was sitting next to a
guy
at a play who i kind of know
he's kind of hard to talk to but but
nice and funny i'm so curious yeah and
he was like how are you and like not and
i was like i know so many of those
people hard to talk to and funny like
you want to get in there
cherish moments of life yeah when it
works it works oh it feels so good you
nailed it yes person who's kind of tough
really and i was sitting next to him and
he was like how are you doing and i was
like well i was like
i'm having an allergic reaction and an
issue with my left ovary so i'm on a lot
of hormones a lot of antihistamines some
steroid cream on my left cheek don't and
then i took a lo and i was like am i
beautiful to you
and it was like there was just nothing
how aroused are you yeah it was that
kind of vibe and he just wouldn't
and then he sort of just like like
leaned forward and like adjusted his
play program and i was like oh it's so
easy for me to still miss the mark and
like i find like yeah but that's funny
see the thing about that and the thing
about glad you took nicely to my texting
because you and i don't know each other
that well but i've always felt so warmly
towards you and i sent you this picture
of myself with like
lotion all over my face and i was like
can't wait to come to your play is there
something on my face see but comedy to
me i think it's important for the world
and for comedy uh to be able to make
that joke and comment on
whether it whether it is funny or not to
you that situation on girls is funny as
it was when you were trying to impress
or make a joke with the guy um am i
beautiful to you yeah that that
that's a funny calling guys i only kind
of know
papa
yeah well yeah
you know stuff like that yeah yes yeah
but that's
they're [ __ ] so so in other words so
there's a lot of the reason i feel like
i could never be on a dating app is
because i have absolutely no sense of
how to appropriately communicate with
someone that you're just meeting okay
but that's what you do as a creative
person right i mean so
what are what are your fears then about
putting
uh you did it on girls for something you
do it every day you do it in life i
don't mind like sort of putting it out
to a diffuse audience i find it much
more intimidating to try to like engage
with a person in a one-on-one way like
if there's an audience
i don't even really hear their response
like i know that they're there i
appreciate that they're there i'm
grateful that they're tuning in but
really i'm making things for me and if
other people
are engaged but when you're dealing with
someone one-on-one you have to like care
about their
pleasure and their response and like i
love to listen and i love to be present
for somebody but i don't know how to
like
i'm pretty um
like basically the two reactions i can
get from people like in a friendship or
dating context is either that they
are like
oh my god this is too much i can't do
like this is i don't know how to engage
with this person or like this is not
comfortable or
they immediately get so comfortable that
i then feel subsumed by their needs and
like overcome by the fact that they're
like i've never felt so comfortable with
anybody and i'm like this is how we talk
to everybody
that people find it people misinterpret
it for intimate as intimacy yes there's
a lot of like i had a real sit down with
myself earlier this year where i was
like i have to really work on like
not allowing sort of like false intimacy
because i don't like the feeling of
disappointing people is so
horrific to me that the idea that
somebody would like engage with me in a
really intimate way quickly and then i
would disappoint them is i mean i'm
really like going this is yeah no we
share that i mean do you feel that way
absolutely because you're very like i
remember you and i were at a barbecue
together a couple years ago and i like
immediately sat down and was like it's
been a pretty weird summer justin yeah
like i felt very safe yes and likewise
and i remember talking to my now
ex-girlfriend afterwards about that
sorry yeah no no we both broke up with
the people we brought to the barbecue
yeah both musicians yep both yeah both
friends i think that's why we were there
yeah so we were both the musicians
they're friends with each other
collaborators and then wouldn't it be
amazing for the story it was like and
then we took them to the barbecue and
they fell in love
yeah and we both had to move out that
day well we would have saved the time we
would have gotten to our next place in
life quicker um but oh my god why is
everyone always breaking up all the time
i know i know i read the daily mail i
know yeah
yeah yeah but you so but but um in terms
of feeling comfortable with somebody i
think that is um
it's something that we should we all i
also want i mean this is like
embarrassing to admit but i want people
to like me i like when people
like i'd like to be like dancing
you know it's not also like wanting
people to like you like
that's what it is i mean i have this
tattoo on my arm that says love me you
went to the wrong arm i just remember
people listening that was funny
but i always look at my love me tattoo
and i'm like i got it sort of because
it's a it's a piece of art that an
artist i love who who passed away did
but
and it looks like um a valentine yeah
it's like a candy heart that says love
me but we all want to be liked like
that's yeah i feel like we have such a
tendency to criticize our own desire to
please but it's like that in and of
itself is not a problem what's the
problem is if you like
present falsely or you want people to
like you because you don't
feel safe in yourself
if you're working out other things that
that
should come out in therapy or something
but but then how do you reconcile that
this is the big question how do you
reconcile that with
i mean certainly that the amount of
flack that you've gotten for the things
that you've said the missteps the public
missteps i mean that's the flip side to
living this kind of
public like how do you deal with that
that's kind of interesting i've been
thinking about this lately which is like
people were like when i started people
were like she's so honest like she's
really raw she's really showing what a
[ __ ] up kind of creature she is and
then it's an interesting thing that you
do that you show people who you are
you're celebrated for it and you're
celebrated for it and then you make
mistakes and people are like but not
those kinds right weird i just hope that
the mistakes i've made and the kind of
conversation i've created around them
are something that was helpful to
someone because i don't mind being
criticized at this point like it's such
a part of my dna like i was never a
popular kid i didn't i was never like
it's just when did you find when did you
become would you say was was there a
moment that you
became popular i mean whatever that
means because because we both exist in
this hollywood is a sort of like you
know version of a relief like when i
when girls first started
and i would like you know go to parties
and people would be like i love you i
love the show i love everything you do
i'd love to work with you or whatever
the thing we all do people all do to
each other when they see each other at
an awards show
yeah the last few years of my life have
really been about like a kind of
slotting off of the people who were
actually not
truly engaged with me or my work and the
people who are left like i was just
talking to with my oldest friend joanna
today and we were like just literally
sitting at the children's bookstore like
drinking coffee and talking and i was
like i was like all the people who i
actually was like in these false
relationships with are gone and that's
the gift also of going through really
hard stuff is that like if people don't
really love you they don't want to hang
around and so what you're left with are
people who love you and understand it's
a real litmus test there's a great line
and almost famous that phil hoffman says
where he goes um you know the only real
currency in this bankrupt world is what
you share with your friends when you're
uncool you're a really gifted
depressionist
that's great that you're kind of like
really like you did a great walk-in
you're
it's crazy
but but phil's close for me because i
love him i just i like doing people that
i you know really that you admire it's
cool to be able to do like i can't even
begin the other night was
um doing this i did like the tiniest
silliest but very fun cameo in the play
that the beastie boys are doing oh wow
spike
jones is one of my best friends and he
told me to come and play bob dylan and i
did it but i can't he was like do your
best bob dylan
i don't have a best bob dylan voice
everyone's got a bob dylan voice i was
kind of like um it was kind of like
come on man like it was so stupid it
wasn't good at all i can't do it that's
why when i did snl i was like i was like
this is not i can't do any of these like
they were like can you do any characters
and i was like yeah i have like a
five-year-old i do who loves the subway
she's like just a five-year-old who
loves the subway and they were like no
like people who exist i was like oh no
no i can't do that but and yet you
capture different voices so accurately
so i love writing different people and i
feel like i can do impersonations of
people's ideas and attitudes while you
so that's how you channel i do an
impression of my agent she always goes
uh if you tell her like if you say to
her like i just don't necessarily feel
like these people understand the uh
female characters and she goes correct
about everything life could be a dream
you're a great student of
the you know human behavior and i i try
i love an observer i mean i try it's
funny because i'm an astute observer
don't break that impression now sorry
sorry i mean but what about you you can
do it with me but yeah this is safe but
i'm just saying
no no no we don't have to cut it but i'm
just saying if you're meeting new
friends
right and you don't know if you're
meeting new friends in the new york
theater scene right
it doesn't go over well if you're
looking for a girlfriend at a feminist
bookshop right
as one does but was he he must have been
somewhat of an influence yeah i
definitely had it's funny though like it
wasn't as much like there are things i
really love about
woody allen of course and and i really
love that he introduced really the
biggest things that he introduced me to
a lot of my favorite actresses oh
interesting so like
diane keaton diane wiest mia farrow like
these you know yeah mira sorvino like
that that's the irony he wrote
incredible parts for women yeah and cast
really great women and so i feel lucky
to have that those women were brought to
my awareness by those movies and i was
really into mike nichols as a kid like
that's a big that's a big one for me i
was lucky enough to meet him i love
elaine may like i love that time in new
york but i have like a slightly i'm an
anxious jew but but anxious jew comedies
like not my fault about my area
interesting quote
anxious jew comedy is not my area says
lena dunham
to angry crowd of yeah anxious about
mitzvah-goers yeah
but then how do you separate that i mean
like any value that you do find let's
say even if it's a performance of of
mia's in you know if it says hannah and
her sisters and all those great female
performers how do you how do you watch
those movies still how do you separate
the art don't i think it's hard for me
to watch them now
i think just knowing what i know and the
cultural discourse that takes place it's
just like it's not like i couldn't watch
it and appreciate it but sort of like
why don't i just watch something that
gives me full joy yeah sure because
there is so much stuff that gives me
full joy and there is so much
like it's the same way where i was just
saying to someone the other day they
were like how am i going to relegate the
michael jacksonville and i'm like i'm
like there's other music
so much that's right go on itunes like
it's not like it's
but also
for me like i like to just keep
expanding like i'm
not like are you a person who likes to
watch the same movies over and over at
night for comfort yes yes see that's a
different like hanging out with an old
friend yeah see i almost never watch a
movie twice sometimes i'll watch it like
one and a half times but i'm sort of
obsessed with the idea that like i'm
gonna leave the world not having
consumed enough so if i consume anything
twice it's like a waste of money oh okay
well i think about that a lot how do you
spend your time in the name of the show
is life is short and not not because
it's like short but it's also i was
saying this to my best friend today she
was like she was like life is short
she's like but it's also so long and
then she says the best thing she was
like and it's the exact amount of time
we need oh that's interesting and i was
like not if you're richie valens you
know or buddy holly i mean no they come
on they needed more time they needed
more time yeah
but but then so so then i i
wrestle with what
and you just sort of answered this in a
way what do you what do you do with that
time how do you feel that time and and
we also talked about this in terms of
like the time you give to people yes and
the energy
that's a lot when you're a people
pleaser like we are that takes a lot of
[ __ ] energy to go to those parties
and i don't do it anymore i mean i made
a rule at the beginning of this year
that i wasn't going to any parties that
had more than five people out there
that's i heard you say that i've mostly
kept it did that have anything to do
with did you ever have social anxiety
did was that because i took klonopin
briefly because of social anxiety it
works it works yeah klonopin works for
social study for a little while the
thing about all those medications is
that what we don't talk about is like
it's the same with opiates it's like
they're meant to be taken for a
short-term problem they're not a
long-term solution yeah and so that is
like the thing that is is the issue with
having such a kind of i mean this all
like has to do with our there's so much
to say about this but also like our
fractured medical system and the fact
that we don't have people getting real
daily attention from doctors and like no
one's getting the amount of time they
need with their medical professionals
and medical professionals want to fix
things as quickly as they can yeah not
to blame them but they have a million
patients and a quote of the film
it's just so broken that there's nobody
to explain
how these things work but yeah i've
totally had periods of social anxiety
but it's more like
i'm not a person who goes to a party and
it's like what am i going to say to
everyone i'm scared it's more that it
takes
takes deeply from me do you gravitate
toward you know people that you know
people that you find come from yes i
have like my best friends i keep them
all in my iphone favorites to make sure
that i like to contact them once a day
just so that they know i love them
that's impressive thank you but they
would probably be like but she never
leaves her house and like i never get to
see her my friend would call that uh
watering your friendship she would say
i'm not good at watering my
relationships
i love to water my relationships if a
friend ever says to me like i feel like
you haven't been focused on me or
whatever i'm like oh my god i'm so sorry
because it's actually like something i
pride myself on wow is being able to
stay yeah in touch with the people that
i love they just told me you gotta leave
in five minutes
yes this is upsetting for me too i'm so
sorry no no no no uh i i want to i would
never do this but i'm i'm running a
business with michael and i guess he
needs me of course i i just want to
circle back really quickly yes
the potential to offend and why i'm
drawn to people who there is very little
potential to offend you strike me as
somebody
who has such a high threshold for things
like that how are you offended i'm so
curious what would offend you i mean
what's that a great question that's a
really great question because i was
actually thinking the other day like oh
my god it's so hard i think that the
thing that offends me most in people is
like a lack of empathy you're right i
find it really one of the things i love
about sobriety which i you and i texted
about yesterday is i love the fact that
when you meet in groups with other
people who have experienced challenging
times and you hear their stories like
it's almost impossible for me not to
love someone when i've heard the story
of their life
and i think when i meet people or when i
encounter in a friend or when even when
i encounter in the public or the media
or in art a lack of empathy for people
in their experience
it's like really
offensive to me because i think that
being able to
think about the interior life of someone
who is not you
is like the greatest thing we can
undertake i think that's why you're a
great writer i think
i think you you have an empathetic eye
toward your characters uh even the ones
who are deeply flawed and i have to tell
you of all the things that you've you've
done and you've created i i have a deep
admiration for your willingness to talk
about flaws because i think it's so rare
now it's so important too
it's hard to be a person it's hard
it's very brave to keep going
and i feel that more now than i ever
have it's funny because i'm turning 33
and i feel so old justin i feel like
i've just been around for maybe it's my
trick knee but i feel like i've been
around for a long time i'm gonna get to
some short questions really quick yeah
because i think you're sure that five
minutes can be ten yeah okay okay well
um
michael's a kind but a benevolent leader
you have to apologize for a lot of
things
are there degrees to which you
there's a bunch of stuff i haven't
apologized for because i feel like i
only really want to apologize when
something when it feels as though
my real position about things has been
like misrepresented
yeah and so if and if i feel like a
group of people who it's important to me
to make them feel safe feel unheard but
i'm
i don't have the same relationship to
social media that i used to like i do
share things but i'm not bobbing around
on there that's big right to go back and
read the stuff and like yeah it's almost
like guerilla warfare you want to like
you post a thing and you i post and i
run right i post and run but also i
don't post the to the same degree and i
honestly were in such a kind of i used
to share a lot about my political
beliefs i'm much more chill i've sort of
picked my battles and my battles like if
there's like if there's a cause i really
only share personal things if i think
they can be useful to other people
rather than just a sort of i think when
i was younger i maybe was not as
discerning and i was sort of like don't
anyone if anyone i love tried to tell me
like hey lena maybe you didn't need to
like post your feelings about that in
the middle of the afternoon i'd be like
don't try to control me
and now i would love for someone to try
to control me
um who doesn't who has control over you
in your life who do you go to my parents
are a big one like i really i really try
to listen to them i respect their
opinion and also they're such a support
to me and they're so like my partners in
the world in a certain way that there's
that it's important to me that they feel
comfortable and they've been creative
partners
despite your mother's seeming reticence
sometimes to have her stuff out there
she's very
she's like
she's really like thinks i'm a walking
disaster but
no but we're best best friends and my
dad is one of my best friends and my
sibling is one of my best friends and
and then also you know the people i work
with like i run a company and the people
that work for me michael
liz soham marissa
it's important to me that they feel safe
and like they're that the company is not
just about like pushing my voice forward
but it's about bringing together and we
together make a real um
like we have a diverse array of
perspectives and i want them to feel
like uh
like they are heard and like they're
part of it because i'm not interested in
uh it's this is a this is a
democracy not a cherokee yeah hey bring
it on reference um short questions
really sure yeah if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play and why hockey i just wanted to
i'm so excited to be able to talk about
this what i'd never been to a sports
game i went to the last rangers home
game of the season oh my god i sat
by the rink whatever that's called
yeah firstly
i was so turned on get out of here it's
crazy how hot they are and i do not have
an interest in athletes i do not have an
interest in hot bodies i do not have an
interest in masculinity and i was like i
was with my friend who's a straight-up
lesbian and she was like i am horny like
yeah so intense and they gave me a
t-shirt and then one of the guys threw
me a t-shirt and then someone gave this
other guy gave me a puck
what yes that's not a metaphor for
anything so that he gave you an house he
handed me a pocket i can make that joke
with you because i felt yeah i felt
crazy i was like oh my god and then yeah
he [ __ ] me and then also i was like
sitting in this area that was all these
like super like seasoned tickets hockey
people and they were all like can you
believe zabanja got a shootout and i was
like no it's crazy like i had no idea
you just assimilated immediately because
you like because i was aroused
is that going to are you going to now
watch the hockey games are you going to
be a fan no never again if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would it be and you smoked pot
i mean that's a subset no i don't smoke
hot because i'm sober so i don't do
anything i don't do um i don't do any
drugs except uh antihistamines i if i
could have one snack food for the rest
smoke a lot of claritin smoke a lot of
claritin and i love snacks and i guess
my
rice pudding oh okay is my favorite food
okay okay uh what's your favorite movie
of all time
my favorite movie of all about my
favorite time is probably uh
the original heartbreak kid uh okay with
charles grodin
oh my god are you charles robinson and
jeannie berlin when jeannie berlin
covers herself in mayonnaise once she
has a sunburn in one of the great cities
yes uh other than la new york where
would you want to live london london
okay i love london uh if you could have
dinner with three people that are alive
who you've never met before i would want
to have dinner with
um
sally rooney she's an irish novelist she
just had a book come out called normal
people i love it and i would want to ask
her questions what a cool answer um
thank you uh and uh uh i would like to
have dinner
with the rock
really i love him dwayne johnson or some
other guy dwayne johnson i love him i
wish he was my dad really
what my feelings about him are totally i
went to see uh uh sam
what's that one movie called uh san
andreas san andreas in the theater with
3d glasses wow and he saves his daughter
he's like hot alexandra tatario yes yes
yeah yeah i just love that they they
like make his daughter so hot isn't it
yeah well she would be hot yeah totally
she's like hot and the right age to be
his wife it's all great but yeah but uh
uh i just was like i love this man he
makes me feel safe like i want to dangle
from a helicopter purely so he can pull
me back up into it
i can sort of see that he's comforting
he's got a comforting
almost non-threatening what a rare
combination i love it and the third
person i would want to have um
dinner with is um
uh is
oh i know exactly who it is it's um
uh paula cher she started a design
studio called pentagram and she like
designs like all of our favorite logos
god i wish that dinner would happen only
because only so i could sort of watch
the rock engage with sound and polish
air be a little bit out of his element
but probably charm the pants off yeah
everyone would love him they'd all go in
being like we have to have dinner with
that's great yeah all he's going to talk
about is his meat intake and he's just
going to surprise them with his
knowledge of like feminist literature um
who's your favorite muppet
yeah and or if you identify with anymore
yeah i'm a janice oh great oh i love
james uh yeah like oh my god um
yeah okay what's um the most commonly
used emoji if you use them i don't know
i do and the one that i like is the
foggy window pane
what which one if you write fog there's
like a foggy window pane there's like
just a square of fog and it's a fun
answer because it's sort of like
ambiguous and like someone can be like
what are you doing this evening i don't
know foggy window pane like that kind of
thing i said it a lot to my dad
and is it a company does he give you
that one the like i don't know my dad's
favorite one is the like um is like the
yellow face that's like holding up a spy
glass to its eyes oh yeah yeah
interesting like that one yeah sleuthing
yeah um okay uh um if you if you had a
vanity plate uh on your car i doubt you
would but what was your i don't know how
to drive um but if i had a vanity plate
it would be like uh
my friend collier
informed me that irene from the real
world started an organization this is
just the first thing that occurred to me
she started a charitable organization
for lyme disease called naps for lyme
naps where people are supposed to take
naps
and like have people like
like pledge money and i would want a
license plate that said naps for lime oh
that's great to promote it and it's also
kind of funny
not lyme disease and people would ask
questions and yeah i could be like well
i'll
check out my uh
yeah check out my license plate which
helps me with irene from real worlds
organization naps for lime uh so uh
lastly i want to get back to the podcast
your podcast is launched now yeah i
co-host it with one of my best friends
her name's alyssa bennett she's like a
real historian she's much much smarter
than me and anyone else we know because
she's not in the entertainment industry
and she's a genius you i don't know i
can't believe i have to remind you that
you're very smart so she must be
intimidating he's insanely smart we
actually met in college i was a freshman
and she and i was 18. she was a freshman
and she was 26 because she had wait for
it a successful modeling career in
belgium first of course so it's so rude
when someone's so smart and like
literally was a successful runway model
yeah you think god what what did god
what flawless
together yeah i hope there's something
but she's the best she's
and we have a really great time hosting
the podcast together and maybe you want
to come on some time and talk about your
favorite crazy woman of history i would
love to and this is about the c word
refers to women throughout
crazy throughout history and we kind of
tried to do a deep dive into their lives
and explain why maybe
we have to live with a little empathy
for them after all well you are the uh
embodiment of that i think you've shown
it in your work and i want to thank you
for contributing to our culture and your
voice i know that sounds but i i mean it
uh my epitaph is gonna say justin was so
sweet to her
annie justin bartha thoreau um uh i i
honestly i think we're better off for it
and i want to thank you for coming on my
show this show is definitely better off
for it i love this show
it's my favorite show oh you know it's
my go-to show it's the rice pudding of
chose oh that means a lot knowing
knowing how much that means to you uh so
thank you and thank you guys for
listening thank you
so that happened
um
so what do you what it what what were
your thoughts my overarching
thought throughout was i felt like i was
eavesdropping
on a really interesting conversation in
a restaurant like the table next to me
because you could hear clinking of
plates yeah because i kept you kept
asking rudely for more food
um no i was i i felt like i was at a
restaurant and i was jealous of the
table next to me because they were
having a better time than i was having
oh that's that's um i thought it was
interesting that she said she never
watches or rarely watches a movie twice
because she's obsessed with this idea
that she'll leave the world without
consuming enough and
this certainly ties into
the life is short theme of the show and
that
she wants to do as much as possible
while she's here and watching home alone
for the second time you'll be like you
know that the parents are going to come
back at the end you're like why watch
that again wait oh i'm sorry [ __ ]
spoiler alert america thanks a lot
the parents come back she also says the
way she thinks about dying and she talks
about how there's you know people who
want to try everything and just do
everything and that also includes
dying it's like i'm not ready to do it
yet but that one day will be
an experience to have as part of life
and that um
yeah and it makes it less scary yeah and
and she you know she talked about also
that in her 20s she uh when she went
through some [ __ ] so now she feels more
comfortable the idea of dying to lose
something that vital
just physically just to to see
a part of your anatomy um a vital part
of your anatomy and like to lose that
already it's it's yeah it's like reduced
to something
oh tangible yeah and well that happened
will that happen
yeah but it must be somewhat and she
talks about that more eloquently than i
could that that is kind of comforting uh
to her um in other a few other little
observations yeah you talk about getting
a tattoo from green day oh yeah which
i'm now regretting i've heard you've
never heard you tell that story yeah um
and
i
am concerned with
the grandma and my grandmother and
mother listening to this because
uh they both
view tattoos as
i don't know where this comes from and i
know i mean it's a different generation
everything but they think people with
tattoos are like
they hate tattoos with a passion that
i've not ever she's it like impugns
someone's character yeah
tattoos which is so strange she will
write off i mean you could be the most
impressive you she she'd write off like
obama if she found out that he had a
little tattoo
yeah um like the chinese symbol for um
for hope
uh his lower back got it when i was in
college i can admit to it um
yeah he she hates them so much and and
i'm now so now mom uh i'm talking to you
directly i'm not talking to one person
and grandma i'm talking to two people uh
the tattoo has since faded to the point
where it's no longer a tattoo there's no
ink on my skin they're just little
indentations neither of whom know how to
listen to podcasts so
you're actually talking to nobody right
now
so we're all dumb with that episode oh
boy sorry
i hope you enjoyed listening to it i
hope you enjoyed that last uh pun um
that's why i leaned into it
the way i did it was a good punim
that nice
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
so thank you guys for listening to life
is short and if you like the show again
please give us a five star review i i
hate groveling but um that's where we're
at we are available on apple podcasts
spotify google podcasts and you know
every major listening app our theme song
is performed by our friend harmar
superstar life is short is hosted by me
justin long produced by christian long
and megan monaco senior producer as
michelle lanz executive produced by
marsha louis and ernan lopez for
wondering
how would you react if christian came
home and let's say he was showing you a
tattoo that said
pearl
forever the heart around it i would go
no no no what would you really do okay
go you sure where is it it's on your own
what do you think
i think it's unfortunate that's what i
think you seem to be so calm you see
you're thinking very well i think that
i'm hoping it's one of those decades
it's not it's perfect now see i swear i
swear it's permanent
well that's very foolish that's all it's
very foolish you want to look like are
you yeah well you're so chilly
so i know you didn't really do it oh
nobody from how would
you want to see me get all upset leave
me alone
no i'm curious how you would what you
would say
what the [ __ ] did you do
you